a really fascinating study just came out
from the University of Winnipeg that
indicates that people who engage in text
messaging are more racist and more
shallow than people who do not the study
observed 2300 psychology students for
three years and let's let's take a look
at some of the numbers here okay so
people that sent a hundred text messages
per day were thirty percent less likely
to concern themselves with living
ethical lives and fifty text messages or
less you are far more likely to care
about living principled lives so this
isn't pretty this is a pretty obvious
thing here you text you don't care about
anybody Erin how often do you text we've
texted you're not an over texture just
the right amount of text 3000 text
messages a day and I only like white
people ridiculous story I mean if you
ask me a question I respond you respond
response poser tux yes
does Winnipeg have any other races white
people texting about people they
probably never see this was not the
right University but it's also college
kids leading ethical lives
no one should lead an ethical life or
their twenties yeah it's just because
young people know you're talking about
rageous numbers people do a hundred text
messages a day are not living their life
they are not in the moment they're
living a virtual life on their phone
that has everyone doing that I mean we
can say that but isn't that what the
kids are all doing oh I mean they're
tweeted texts and all they charge me
crazy that you're in you're in some
event or you're at some party yeah and
you know my nephew's perfect example
there in the corner texting somebody and
it's like and just be in everyone has
their their phone on texting are
horrible racists along with
absolutely being so rude the route the
racist right before you just thought
they didn't want to hear about people
they just don't care they have no
manners and there are they hate Asian
Americans yeah I didn't say that like I
don't care if I run over people in their
driving because they're probably not
white people so it's okay do you think
some of this though has to do with the
technology of it because you're you're
literally disconnecting from the actual
room that you're in as you said you're
in the phone and not surrounded with
people so you're more callous you say
things on texts or in an email that you
would never say to someone to their face
right don't you do that all the time
it's it's much easier to be cold or mean
in a text yeah I mean it's just
absolutely the whole study I think it's
absolutely just ridiculous to me that
you can get like racial profiling from
people that were just like on their
texts and Winnipeg I don't know no I
think I'm gonna need a couple other
studies too you want some more numbers
I hate gingers a lot you can get away
with a lot more in text and you know I
can I can see this notion of ya know I
always tell people don't put it in
writing you're gonna get nailed that's
funny so on one hand you can say a lot
worse things because it's easier than
looking someone in the eye and saying
something bad to them but on the other
hand you're right you're leaving that
digital footprint that's will create all
kinds of other problems general petraeus
hello yeah so do you you tell all your
clients clear off the off the digital
space is that I had one of my clients
showing me these hot nude pictures of
her new boyfriend I said that's really
hot you know but nothing's ever truly
deleted is it nothing is true ever truly
deleted every keystroke is recorded as I
tell my clients yet the head of the CIA
can't keep his computer a secret you
can't keep your as a secret I did he
really try to keep it here like Gmail
you know what he did yeah they had a
gmail account but they never send emails
they would write a draft and put it no
they would write a draft and put it in
the draft folder and they thought
we're never sending it so there's no
trail responsible to safety of the
country he's like I'll put some drafts
in Gmail more secure than Gmail I can
feel that your old kid knows how to get
more like its secure than a draft and
Gmail no I've heard a lot of interesting
ways that people do it I was yeah I
heard of a crime I heard of a crime that
was broken this big embezzlement scheme
and two guys were communicating through
manhunt which is a gay hook-up site
right and they would send messages there
if they got caught by law enforcement
because clearly gay hookup sites are a
lot more secure than Gmail remember that
bonobos comm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report I want to put you
in this slim [ __ ] shirt go to bonobos
calm enter code
TRR to zero for 20% off your next
purchase